so as she gets the microphone inshallah
were going to say the Shahada in Arabic
and Arabic then will we have a sister
who's accepting Islam hamdulillah that's
a blessing hamdulillah may Allah grant
our steadfastness ok she's about to
accept Islam and for you to accept Islam
you have to other the universal
declaration of faith according to the
Islam which is they believe in one God
which we call monotheism which is really
something that was already delivered and
conveyed in the taurah injeel
[Music]
[Music]
that ilaha illallah WA ash hadu
[Music]
[Music]
so we're gonna say this in your language
I'm gonna be the one with the accent I
bear witness so you're gonna say I bear
witness that there is no deity there is
no deity you see I must have the accent
no deity worthy of my worship of my
worship and Submission except Allah
glorified and exalted and I bear witness
that Muhammad peace be a good name is
the Messenger of Allah that be
[Music]
[Laughter]
sister accepting Islam and when a person
has found out that they have a purpose
in life so they asked the owner of life
the one who created this whole universe
and everything in it
that's the creator alone to guide you
and then you're guided you investigate
all the different religions you put all
the religions on the table we look at
the proof and evidences and then you
find without a shadow of a doubt that
Islam provides all of the proof that you
need a human being needs to know that it
is the truth from the Creator Islam
submission to the will of God now you're
ready to submit that first step is
acknowledging was in your very nature
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the Creator that happens in earth
and Muhammad is the last and final
messenger sent to mankind this would
automatically include not exclude all
the preceding messengers who came with
the same message
worshipping the crater at the creation
Islam
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
preceding messengers that's in this
testimony that she just made you got to
witness it here at the mosque thank you
guys from last year this picture was
where you guys promised Becca's dad we
always watch your shows in like really
interesting and it gives us you know
like motivation all your shows are like
description um you know whatever in
Arabic you always explain you know in
English and it's like really really
helpful given for the Muslims to you
know it gives us inspiration you know to
pray and like try to do what you're
doing
so for example personally for me it
really gives big motivation so may Allah
continue to reward you for what you're
doing and make you steadfast to do more
I mean Shaolin yeah right no he's the
Dean show guy right here I know I mean
he did but not on that
a question about me I asked you about
mixed martial arts yes did I say
something that is sit there for everyone
rushed to make the hunties that watch to
make so once you have the capacity do it
don't wait and may Allah support Allah
accept inshallah and rewarded for them
what about the people that now they've
been planning every year they go to
Egypt make sure they make me Walt Disney
World pressure but they forget to make
the Hajj trip there's the things of
Allah Hodja trip is Omaha especially is
very cheap but when you try to go
anywhere else or maybe do something like
that you will be spending a lot money
then you are going to the ambra I would
say honor may be cheaper than Hajj but
is still dead I believe that in anyone
who live in u.s. it's in his capacity
that to able to make Hajj ROM so I will
say that let the money being a cause of
allah subhanaw taala
not to cause of the Shaitaan for sure
that entertainment it is part of our
Deen too but sometimes also we need to
give it to Allah as well thank you very
much
Salaam alaikum
Salam alaikum this love this is what's a
pinky
you've got to MA oh you're I'm gonna go
they know about yes so how about our
friend here great maybe one day in show
I noticed that what I used what I
usually do and I travel and I see that
in the security guard but this guy has a
famous beam troll you know what this
whole deal yeah that's the guy yeah so
shake what I'd like to ask them is
because you guys are here why because
there's a lot of Islamophobia there's a
lot of threat against Muslims and
whatnot but you know not being in this
room what what is your oppression
getting to hang out with Muslims and
actually coming to security guard yeah
like what what what stops you you've
learned a little bit about Islam right
yeah what stops you from becoming Muslim
Sheikh he hasn't learned enough okay I
call you brother yeah he can become a
Muslim then learn any change Sahara yeah
today a woman in the back did you hear
us became almost more the Shahada yeah
yeah yeah Maui's I mean do you believe
in one god yeah that's all what we
believe in is that symbol is this
messenger
that he was sent as a messenger you know
you wanna say this I testify can you say
that I testify can you say that yeah I
testify that there is no one there's no
worthy of my worship worthy of my
worship and submission and submission
except the Almighty Allah the Almighty
Allah and he sent messengers and he said
to show me to show me how to submit to
him how to submit to him and one of
these messengers and one of these
messengers is Jesus Jesus Moses thank
you so you guys just got to witness one
of the security guards accepting Islam
and some might say well what happened
say you didn't explain to him you know
the the pillars of the Articles of Faith
for the pillars of Islam and she
should've took longer and whatnot some
people are thinking that so what would
you say now to them that you made it
very simple practical it was just very
fast you know what would you say to
people you see we're supposed to invite
people to Islam and show them how to
enter Islam the prophets of Salaam would
would receive people who had zero
knowledge about Islam and then he will
construct his learned companions to
teach them you know what does it take to
implement a slam now but in principle he
agreed to the fact that there is one
deity worthy of worship no one else is
he actually negated been affirmed and
that's what is the Shahada is is like
that you negate any affirm and then
afterwards you you know you accepted the
concept of messengership that there are
messengers who show us the way to God to
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
and I named them and Mohammed was one of
them and so he's in principle accepting
the whole you know concept is now just a
matter of learning how to implement that
submission that concept of submission
and praying 5 times and learning more
about the haters Allah and he's not that
the same one in Christianity and Judaism
rather he's unique pertaining to his
names and attributes and actions and so
that's we you know that the knowledge
comes handy but you see the at one time
III tried to to pull this on someone and
he rejected it he wouldn't say it you
know what what what got him and and this
is the beauty of the Shahada ad that it
begins with negation that you have to
cancel out any deities any gods before
affirming God affirming Allah you see
that's why the Shahada has the negation
than the affirmation that the school as
they call it nephew Nam general negation
that you negate the existence of any
deity anyone worthy of worship then you
affirm it to Allah so as soon as I
started negating he said no I Jesus I
can negate Jesus this guy didn't get he
didn't stop he didn't he didn't just
float he know this guy he floated this
guy flow yes yes floated with it so he's
in principle and that's by the way the
majority of the people are this way
because this is the part of your nature
yeah yeah yeah because what I what what
we said to him makes sense you know it
makes sense it just it rhymes with with
what logic with
would would end with the intuition is
called the filter out you know so would
shake would you recommend now for
someone to go let's say is it needed
or is it encouraged so the community can
welcome him let's say next week to go
and help him go in front just like the
sister made the Shahada today to go to
go ahead and bring him in front of
everyone and to make the same thing that
he just did yeah absolutely yeah but
again it's not technically it's not
needed
it's not needed but it's it's all it's
better to do to take it into a
congregational level yeah because you
can say like he died tomorrow yes so the
people would know that he's a Muslim and
and if he has made that commitment so
probably enough that he's gonna be on
that intro shake let's talk about let's
summarize you grave a a a very inspiring
hood but today it was on Jenna right and
some of the points that you mentioned if
you can just go ahead for our audience
that that wasn't there one one of them
was you you you gave a beautiful example
how in this life even Prophet Abraham he
called his father to submission to the
will of God you know in all of us we had
to call our families we have to call
humanity but that's it once this life is
over you can't go retake the test it's
finished so let's talk about that part
you know and
highlight that and I want to get more of
because you cover some great points in
your hood but this point right there
well first of all is is is is the
spreading compromising language and in
the Muslim world now that Jenna is for
everybody and people would use ambiguous
evidence to establish that even though
the crystal-clear one is dear and I
quoted the one of these crystal clear
evidence that only those who accepted
that universal declaration of faith
which I we shared with this brother
Alvarez his name you know
only those who will accept it well let
the enough cbid bear the one in whose
hand my soul is none of you none of them
I'm sorry liya smile be I hadn't mean
her Allah none of them will hear about
me and he never accepts me he will be a
dweller fail in reference here to Jews
and Christians listen this is not a
language of Dawa but this is a belief
system that you must believe that you're
yourself so the story of Ibrahim that
here he is his own father and Ibrahim
has a status you know what Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala says what tough Allahu brahim
of Adila and that's the point I was
making regardless of what your statuses
and he wanted to intercede on behalf of
his father and his father
you know big him actually to do so even
though he expelled him and he threatened
him of stoning if he doesn't stop
calling him to Islam and he was
forcefully stopped from calling I would
think a brain would have carried on
calling his father to Islam wouldn't
have wouldn't he have been
ten by him but yet in the day of
judgment he wants him to help him out
and he said no Allah said no no in mere
Haram to genital and this is why also
you understand any that why did the path
the prophets assalam big his uncle to
say that Kalam add a bit of death and
and this is why we're supposed to ask
people to say it before they die and and
and and so forth because it's simply
[Music]
your key to Jenna without it forget it
yeah there was a particular ayah that
you recited about Jenna in the hood bar
what was this ayah it was pertaining to
in context will the the contract which
we have it's only signed and I I kind of
took it back using the word sign with
Allah because there is no such an
attribute but the contract is written
and Allah subhana Allah is guaranteeing
his side of the contract that you
believe in Allah and you submit to Allah
and you strive to be a good Muslim and
return the payment is Jenna and and this
is a promise and Allah will fulfill his
promise
because breaking promises is a sign of
imperfection and allah subhanaw taala is
above all imperfections that verse in
surah at-taubah in la Hache terminal
menina and fazham o my Allah whom be an
illusion indeed Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
has already purchased from
they're believers you know has basically
imagine all of us down low giving us the
life or giving us that children were
given us the wealthy giving us
everything but yet he's willing to take
it back from us in lieu of gender and
and that's the verse that I was
referring to and I was encouraging the
congregation to sign to take their on
their part of the another part of the
dealin and be submissive wrapping it up
so pretty much how simple is the formula
to get to Jenna is it fine is one gonna
get there on their own like whims and
desires you talked about that or by
submitting their will entirely to the
creator and you and you mentioned given
your best you have you see first of all
there is no you can talk if you have not
accepted a lot to be your Creator maker
success sustainer provider you have to
accept that you have to believe that
he's the one who benefits the one who
causes harm the one who gives you the
life and on who will cause you to die
everything is in the hands of Allah so
you must believe that and that's what we
called her hate you see allah subhanaw
taala said in a hadith qudsi hadith
Allah he also enough Adam if you come in
the day of judgment would earth filled
with sins but with one restriction that
you have not violated monotheism to hate
you know Allah can forgive you that is
why our belief system by the way people
who commit major sins they are under the
will of Allah subhana Allah
they are under the will of Allah so no
one can say that they are going to hell
for for sure because they are under the
will of Allah subhana Allah so the first
thing is to hate after that striving you
know I say striving because no one is
perfect I'm the first one sitting here
sinners here I said I fall into since we
all do nobody is perfect so the first
thing that you need to take care of is
your tau Hitler illa allah muhammad
rasool allah and after that just strive
do your best and then count on allah has
mercy count on allah his forgiveness and
Allah says I'm the way my slave think of
me